i i i like to kind of parachute the
audience into the story that's already
going 60 miles an hour the properties of
people and the properties of character
have almost nothing to do with each
other you can write heroes you can write
villains but there's no such thing as an
interesting character who doesn't have a
conscience it isn't and i don't think it
should be journalism i i don't think
what you want from art is a wikipedia
page shot nicely it ought to be
subjective and not objective i love uh
compressing time and
space
i love those
that claustrophobic almost play-like
feeling in the process of writing the
first draft by the time you get to the
end you've sort of discovered what the
movie is about go back to the beginning
of the script start writing it over
again
peel away the things that don't have
anything to do with your story get it
down to its fighting weight well i think
anyone who doesn't respect the audience
is making a big big mistake i don't
think that the people who make movies
are any smarter than the people who
watch movies if you treat them like
they're dumb they're not going to like
you very much
[Music]
jd may asks what are your best tips for
writing villain characters okay that's a
great question and my best tip is that
you jd cannot think of them uh as a
villain you can't judge the character
you're the writer you can't judge the
character you have to be able to
empathize with that character find
something about that character
that is like you too and then you have
to write that character like they're
making their case to god why they should
be allowed into heaven i don't know if
you've ever seen the first movie i wrote
was based on the first play that i wrote
a few good men and you probably know you
can't handle the truth uh that whole you
can't handle the truth scene from
nicholson in the courtroom that is
nicholson's character making his case to
god why he should be allowed into heaven
even though
he has committed manslaughter okay even
though he's responsible for the death of
a marine private he's defending it why
it was actually a good thing to do so
whether it's mark zuckerberg the founder
of facebook or nicholson and a few good
men or anybody else the audience can
think of them as a villain but not you i
do think of a dialogue and musical term
it is music it's not uh that that isn't
a metaphor anytime that you're speaking
out loud for the sake of performance
those words what you're saying have all
of the properties of music rhythm beats
rests exactly right and so there are
musical rules that that that apply if
music if you're in 4 4 time there have
to be four beats in a measure there
can't be three there can't be five you
put time signatures on your dialogue i
do not put them there but they are there
which is why the actor will know that if
he or she has dropped a word from a line
or substituted a two-syllable word with
a one-syllable word it doesn't sound
right uh it doesn't sound as good the
joke doesn't work it's a snappy comeback
uh isn't a snappy it is musical i don't
put time signatures uh in there but what
i do do is
script every sound that's made all the
verbal hiccups all the ums and oz uh
happen jessica has a line in the movie
jessica chastain uh who plays the lead
plays molly uh she has a line in the
movie which is uh the line is i'm a brat
or i was a brat but the line actually
is
i was a brat and it's written m
m
m
i was a brat and uh the first time we
did it i said to her jessica there are
three more m's uh and there are uh you
got to do all the amps
it came from a love for dialogue it came
from my parents taking me to slays that
i was too young to understand like who's
afraid of virginia woolf when i was nine
years old no idea what was going on up
there but i really loved the sound of
dialogue and it sounded like music to me
and i wanted to imitate that sound well
i think anyone who doesn't respect the
audience is making a big big mistake uh
lucy's right when she says um
uh
she's arguing with jeff uh jeff she's
arguing with jess oppenheimer tony hale
um uh about
a moment in a scene
um uh and jess says you think we're
saying ricky is stupid and she says i
think we're saying the audience is and
that's something for which they will not
soon forgive you uh and i i couldn't
agree with her more
um
if you
uh
if you include the audience if they're
not just spectators if they're
part of this event if you can make them
a participant i i like to start
i i like to kind of parachute the
audience into the story that's already
going 60 miles an hour um if you can
make them just sit forward a little bit
to try to catch up uh to where we are
because we're running out ahead of them
um
uh
that
excitement
will be part of their experience um uh
if you
if you treat them like they're dumb um
you
they they're not going to like you very
much and i don't like the story they're
telling and frankly um i you know i i
don't uh
uh i i don't think that the people who
make movies or any smarter than the
people who watch movies here's what's
key uh in in creating drama intention
and obstacle
that's what you've got to cling to
somebody wants something something
standing in their way of getting it they
want the money they want the girl they
want to get to philadelphia they want to
win the big game they want to save
someone's life if somebody wants
something something formidable is
standing in the way of getting it the
tactics that your protagonist uses to
try to overcome that obstacle or those
series of obstacles
that
is
what's going to create your character
because you're not going to tell us who
this character is you're gonna show us
what this character wants
it doesn't matter if they succeed or
fail uh in their quest it matters to you
it doesn't matter to story telling it's
just a good story if they fail as if
they succeed um uh what matters is that
the intention
be important to them and that we
understand why it's important to them
and the obstacles have to be real
attention and obstacle
um i think one of the really the smart
things i think not that i'm smart but
like the way that you took these real
true events and just happened to have
them all happen over one week
i
love uh compressing time and and space
i love those
that claustrophobic almost play-like
feeling
uh so there were these three things that
happened these three uh big events in in
their life
the the accusation that lucy was a
communist um uh the fact that lucy was
pregnant at a time when a woman could
not possibly be pregnant on television
uh and the third was
desi showing up on the cover of
confidential magazine a gossip rag with
another woman in the headline desi's
wild night out
uh and
i thought well you know i'm not
perverting history uh or or um
defaming these people if i take those
three events and make them happen during
one week compress time
and have the whole thing take place
during one production week of i love
lucy monday table read to friday
audience taping
so uh that's what i did dramatists get
to do that the properties of people and
the properties of character have almost
nothing to do with each other
uh uh they really don't i know it seems
like they do um because we we look alike
uh uh characters and people uh but
people don't speak in dialogue their
lives don't unfold in a series of scenes
that form uh a narrative arc uh the
rules of drama are uh
really very much separate from
uh from what we know uh from the like i
said the properties of life with steve
jobs that the thing that has surprised
me is how surprised some people uh have
been uh that it's not a literal biopic
that it's uh not a what we're used to a
cradle to grave story where you'll land
on the greatest hits of the character uh
along the way i can tell you that i i
didn't distort pervert or invent any
facts about steve jobs for this movie at
all except one which is that steve did
not have confrontations with the same
five people 40 minutes before every
product launch that he did that's
plainly a writer's construct just like
if i wanted to write a movie about you
an interesting way to do it might be to
have the whole thing set right here
right at this round table or other
conversations even if it's a cradle to
grave biography yes uh you um remember
the whole thing uh uh of course it's
never the whole thing and it's but and
moreover it isn't and i don't think it
should be journalism it i i don't think
uh what you want from art is a wikipedia
page shot nicely it ought to be
subjective and not objective
frequently um if i'm really stuck uh
i'll go out into a like a a public place
a diner
a bus stop
any place where you might overhear a
conversation
and hope that i can land in the middle
of a conversation that will get me
thinking how in the world did this what
in the world was the beginning of this
conversation uh and i'll try to write
that um i and so i was i was in a a
diner once um and just overheard
somebody i mean they were really
frustrated saying i mean honestly how
many people can you think of named
gordon
uh
and i thought let me get out of here i
just want to write the rest of the scene
i'm gonna write the beginning of this
scene um i i i i was in jackson
mississippi um and passed by a park
bench um and uh uh uh two men were
sitting there and one of them said who
that they're going to get the jump on
jesus um and again i thought that's
that's what i'm talking about
he wrote the best line of the scene now
let me just write the rest of it
now uh aaron 2020 has been one for the
books i'm curious does watching a year
like this play out make you want to
write about it and what would the finale
look like please tell me it won't be
revenge of the murder hornets
uh it wouldn't be if i wrote it uh i
think but uh listen a lot will be
written about these uh about these last
few years uh by screenwriters and by
playwrights but uh my my prediction is
that you'll never see donald trump as an
on-screen character that will always be
off screen that you'll see him on
televisions and news footage
because he's simply implausible
as a character
uh and i you you can write heroes you
can write villains but there's no such
thing as an interesting character who
doesn't have a conscience you've written
a scene
well
and and um
you have uh if there are any pool
players in here you'll know what i mean
by giving yourself a leave um uh which
is to say you've written a scene well
and you you and you've left off at a
place where you can go to bed knowing
what you're doing when you're going to
get up when you get up tomorrow morning
that you're not going to get up tomorrow
morning uh climbing the walls because
you don't have an idea um that you know
just what you're going to do you're
giving yourself a lead all right holly
jack
uh people who write stuff
how do you approach second drafts blank
page and start again amendments to what
you've already got any thoughts tips
would be appreciated yeah great second
drafts are really important a friend of
mine once uh said about me that uh i
don't write scripts i rewrite scripts
and here's what he meant in the process
of writing the first draft by the time
you get to the end you've sort of
discovered what the movie is about uh
because it may not end up that first
draft being about what you thought it
was going to be about when you started
writing it you plotted a course to go
due north but as you were going you
started going a little bit east and then
a little bit more east and when you end
up you're
you're going northeast so you've figured
out uh what the script is about it's
probably fat it's probably long go back
to the beginning of the script start
writing it over again
peel away the things that
don't have anything to do with your
story hang a lantern on the things that
you need to bring into relief uh in the
story you're gonna discover that
a problem that you have in the third act
isn't really in the third act it's
because you didn't set it up properly in
the first so second drafts i say
retype the whole thing sharpen up that
joke that's kind of clunky sharp enough
that's that dialogue that's kind of
clunky get it down to its fighting
weight that's what i do anyway
uh i take
uh anywhere between six to eight showers
a day
um
because i'm not i'm not exaggerating i'm
not exaggerating i'm not a germaphobe it
has nothing to do with germs it's all
about a fresh start uh okay um i was
writing i was writing was not going well
i'm i'm writing badly start again take a
shower put on different clothes um uh
and you'll feel refreshed and uh and
start again writing is really hard for
me i haven't had uh an easy one this one
steve jobs uh uh what was hard was that
i knew what i didn't want to do which
was write a biopic a traditional biopic
a cradle to grave story uh that i wanted
to do something else and what that
turned out to be was uh frankly a a lot
of dialogue um
and uh which if
you are a little familiar with my work
it's not that surprising when i grew up
in my family at
my family's dinner table anybody who
used one word when they could have used
10 just wasn't trying hard enough i see
people are talking over each other yeah
and you know when i really
like everybody in my family is smarter
than i am all of my friends are smarter
than i am all my friends growing up were
smarter than uh than i was and i really
started to enjoy the sound of smart
people arguing with each other and i
wanted to imitate that sound caitlyn
greenridge says if you are writing a
marginalized character whose identity
you do not share
can you imagine your way into that
character through their joy and not
their imagined trauma
yes uh you can
empathy uh
right same blood that goes through your
body goes through that person we all
have as humans the power to empathize
with each other uh to understand each
other's lives and to put any character
we want into a dramatic situation
because the most important thing in your
story isn't going to be someone's sexual
orientation their skin color their
religion whether they are able-bodied or
disabled the most important thing is in
your story is going to be intention and
obstacle what does this character want
and what's standing in their way of
getting it and i assume that because
you're interested in telling this story
you are interested in what the character
wants and what's standing in their way
of getting it or you think it's a great
comic premise with which you can use
your sense of humor or you think it's a
great premise with wish to tell a murder
mystery or a romantic comedy or anything
like that
but i really think it's important that
writers
not
start to get cautious because they're
scared of
of being offensive
stereotypes should be avoided
whether it's as you say someone from a
diverse population or someone who looks
exactly like you
um
you want to avoid all kinds of
stereotypes not just because of uh
racial or ethnic uh sensitivity
stereotypes are just bad in uh in
writing uh you mentioned the rules there
are rules uh they were written over 2000
years ago
by aristotle in a short book called the
poetics the rules of drama are older
than christianity
uh and a a young writer would do well to
learn those rules
when people are talking about something
it isn't so much their position that i'm
trying to imitate as the
as the way they're presenting it i'm
just trying to phonetically recreate the
sound of political sophistication and uh
and and knowing what you're talking
about and oftentimes in in things that
i've written um whether it's a few good
man or uh i wrote a movie called malice
the american president uh or sports
night or the west wing uh
there'll be a quick passage uh that'll
go by and you know somebody the studio a
producer someone will say you know gee
no one's gonna know what these two
people are talking about you know i'll
say it's actually not important that
they do what's important is that the
audience say wow these guys really know
what they're talking about uh that's
interesting and that's what i try to do
i'm a great audience member i uh uh when
when i come into a movie theater when i
come into a theater to see a play when i
turn on the television set uh i i'm the
best audience member you could ask for
you can show me a magic trick 50 times
and i'll still be amazed by it but what
i do do and what i would recommend to
you were talking about young writers
before
is
be a student uh as well have a good time
watching the movie the first time or the
second time the third of the fourth or
the fifth but at some point
be a diagnostician if
if you don't like the movie if the movie
isn't working don't just shrug it off
and say well these guys uh they made a
chunky movie figure out why uh uh what
went wrong
in there so if something if you see
something you don't like it it's not
working figure out why if you
see something and you do like it and
it's working figure out why um figure
out how the magic trick
is done to go back to that metaphor and
then go back to enjoying the magic trick
uh you write some just incredible
dialogue uh what is your secret so i can
let other writers know uh and make other
people's scripts better
well thank you um and i i would tell
those writers to uh uh to write in their
voice uh to uh uh to to not try to write
the way someone else writes uh there's
nothing wrong with you know i i try to
let sort of david mamet get into my
bloodstream i try to let tom stoppard
get into my bloodstream
any number of writers who i revere
uh but i can tell you that when i'm
writing i am talking out loud i'm
playing all the parts uh in my head
and uh
one of the things i think that helps
with
is you are less likely to write a line
of dialogue that's unspeakable um
you know you're i love you my dear like
the stars love the you know it once you
have to say it out loud uh you'll get
the message that you can't ask an actor
to try to
you know casualize that we're going to
talk about character and hopefully
mostly how aaron develops character
so i'm just gonna the first question is
just walk me through pick a character do
you do you write like a short story
about them do you write prose about them
before you do dialogue do they come from
real people how does a character
actually come about in your mind i don't
do those things that you just mentioned
other people do and uh
it's important to note that there is no
one way to do it everybody uh does it
differently for me
uh
rather than kind of tell the audience uh
uh who a character is i like to show the
audience what a character wants
uh uh and it all boils down to intention
and obstacle somebody wants something
something standing in their way of
getting it uh it they they want the girl
they want the money they want to get to
philadelphia uh it doesn't matter but
they have to want it bad if they can
need it uh that's even better something
formidable is standing in their way and
the tactics that that
character uses
to overcome the obstacle is going to
define uh
who the character is it's it's like
having a christmas tree and then hanging
on
frankly the best career advice i've ever
gotten was probably go for god's sake
don't try to be a professional writer
you'll starve to death
i i couldn't follow that advice because
i so badly wanted to be a professional
writer
uh
but
it
it was practice
uh that writing is
like playing the violin
it takes practice you get better as you
get older
uh and uh you just um
don't get beaten down by rejection
you